>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Larry R. Sarratt:
Good afternoon, everyone!
>> Good afternoon!
>> Larry R. Sarratt:
I'm Larry R. Sarratt,
President of the Daniel A. P.
Murray African American Cultural
Association of the
Library of Congress.
I want to take --
[ Applause ]
I want to take this opportunity
to welcome each of you here today
for our program, and we want
to have a special welcome
to our special guest,
Donnie Simpson, for coming
and sharing with us today.
Again --
[ Applause ]
We welcome each of you,
and enjoy our program.
At this time, Theresa Sims,
Theresa Mims Davis will come
and give us the introduction
of our guest speaker.
[ Silence ]
[ Applause ]
>> Theresa Mims Davis:
Good afternoon, everyone!
>> Good afternoon!
>> Theresa Mims Davis: Donnie
Simpson began his career at the age
of 15 at the urban contemporary
radio station, WJLB, in Detroit,
Michigan, where he
remained for eight years.
In 1977, he relocated to Washington,
D.C. In 1983, Simpson was recruited
by Bob Johnson, Founder of BET,
to host the network's primetime
music video show, Video Soul.
Simpson remained with the show
until its cancellation in 1997.
He hosted the Donnie Simpson
Morning Show in Washington, D.C.,
on radio station WPGC-FM from
March 1993 to January 2010.
Currently he hosts the Donnie
Simpson Show in D.C. on Majic 102.3.
Simpson is the first urban
formal radio personality
to have an annual salary of
over one million without,
without being syndicated.
[ Applause ]
He was Billboard's 1998 Air
Personality of the Year.
Ladies and gentlemen, I
present to you Donnie Simpson.
[ Applause ]
>> Donnie Simpson: Wow!
Thank you!
Oh, my goodness.
[ Laughter ]
That million dollar number has
been out there for so long.
It's so funny to me.
I just laugh every time I hear it
because it's just, I don't know,
I mean, it, it, what it are?
You know? It, it is an honor,
but that's not why we do it.
[ Laughter ]
But it's nice that
they pay you for it.
As a matter of fact, I was
just telling the guys Thursday,
during Thursday and
Friday show, I said,
I even said it on the air I think.
I, it's just still amazing to
me that they pay me for this.
You know, because I
have so much fun.
You know, I just love what I do.
You know, we sit there, man, shoot,
especially Thursday and Friday.
We got the TV on, we're
watching the Master's.
We got Teddy Pendergrass
and Luther playing.
You know, telling jokes
and having fun.
It's like, wow!
And you get a check at the
end of the day, you know,
and I've been blessed to get away
with that for all my life, you know.
Since I was 15, I've worked four
hours a day, five days a week,
no weekends, all the
fun I can stand.
I mean, I, you know, it's
like God is so good to me.
[ Applause and Laughter ]
He is. I'm telling you.
Oh, so, well she kind of told
you how it started, so you know,
I guess I should give
you some background.
I started, I, Detroit boy.
Born and raised in Detroit.
Home of Motown.
And growing up in Motown was
such a special occasion for me.
It was just, wow!
You know, we used to watch
every Cadillac that went by,
just hoping that you'd see
Diana Ross or Marvin Gaye or one
of the Temptations or
one of their cousins.
That would have been just as cool!
That's exciting too.
Barber, anybody, anybody
that knows them, you know.
And so, wow!
I'm skipped way ahead here
because I want to say this.
That it's just amazing to me
that all these years later
that these people are
friends of mine.
You know, that I just don't quite
understand how that all happened.
You know, it's just,
well, here's a video
that so many people have
mentioned that it's on YouTube.
It's with me and Aretha
Franklin on Video Soul,
and I don't remember how
the conversation started,
but somehow it went
to Curtis Mayfield,
and we were doing a two-hour special
at Aretha's house, and so she start,
I'm sitting there with her at her
piano, and she just starts singing.
Someone mentioned my favorite song
is The Makings of You, and she,
add a little sugar, honeysuckle
and, and I just started crying.
I just started crying because there
was so much in that moment for me.
You know, it was like
how did I get here?
How, how did this happen?
You sitting on the
queen's throne, one on one,
greatest voice I've
ever heard in my life,
singing to me, one
on one, in my ear.
How did this, how did this happen?
I'm not worthy, you know.
Surely they're going to put me
out of here in a minute, you know.
But it's just, but you know what,
I guess God puts you exactly
where he wants you to be, and so,
you know, I'm grateful for it.
I, I still don't quite understand
how it has all happened, you know,
for this little boy from Detroit
who admired these people so to grow
up to become, you know,
their friends and, you know,
to, it's just, I don't know.
It's overwhelming to me.
It really is.
To be here today, to see
this kind of welcome is,
it's just, it's overwhelming.
When I came back to radio after
five and half years' retirement,
I mean all of the, the, the press
and the attention and stuff,
it was just, I, I, I don't know.
I guess I never get used to it.
It's just, when I retired, you know,
and to see it on the front
page of the Washington Post.
You know, above the fold.
I'll never forget.
I got --
[ Laughter ]
Seriously.
You know, I picked up
the paper that morning.
I saw that.
Immediately tears just
came to my eyes
and I just said, so
it was like that?
You know, because,
you, you know, when,
when you do what you
do, you do what you do.
You know, it's just, I, I'm
rambling, but that's what I do.
I'm sorry.
But there is a, a line from
Elton John song, Rocket Man,
that I love so much where he says in
all the science I don't understand.
It's my job five days a week.
You know, people look at,
you know, he's a rocket man,
you know, he's an astronaut.
It's just what he does.
You know, it's just what I do.
And so you, I'm blessed
that I have gotten to do it.
You know, I took off five and a half
years where I ran a shovel service,
shoveling grandbabies
back and forth --
[ Laughter ]
-- to school.
And --
[ Laughter ]
-- and I was good at it too.
Shoot!
[ Laughter ]
In the summer I was a pool boy.
I was good at that.
I'm still for hire, you know.
We do the G-rated version, then I do
the adult version in Speedos, but --
[ Laughter ]
-- but, but, you know, it was, when
they worked out the deal for me
to come back, they,
my, my best friend.
I can't call him my agent or
attorney because he's neither.
He's just my boy, but he's
done all my contracts.
And he says well, you know what,
there's, the only reason for you not
to do this now is because
you just don't want to do it.
I mean is there a reason you can
think of that, to not do this?
I said yeah, well, I can't pick
Norah up from school at three.
[ Laughter ]
He said well, you can
shout her out on the radio.
She'd probably like that better.
[ Laughter ]
So, you know, so, you know, I take
them to school in the morning and,
and I get to play music for them in
the afternoon, which is pretty cool.
I was asked to talk about
some people here in D.C.
that have impacted my life
and so I guess one I'd
like to lead with, he's not a local.
He's a, he was transported here just
like me, but that's President Obama,
you know, whom I admire greatly.
I have, until 2008, I would all,
the answer to the question who was,
what's the most important
day of your life.
Well, it was two.
It was the birth, the days of
the birth of both my children.
Until that man was
elected president.
[ Laughter ]
Then, yeah, for real.
That's, yeah --
[ Applause ]
That became the greatest
day of my life, you know.
It really was because
that was so much more
than about me and my family and my.
And that was about us, you know,
as a people and as a country.
Not, and I mean not
just black people
but just this country
moving forward.
You know, it was just
that important to me.
And I got a chance to meet him
on the golf course last year.
He was, he came over
to say hello to me.
I was like, wow!
Ok, cool!
[ Laughter ]
And it, and I got it tell you,
it was so funny because we talked
for like a couple of minutes,
and then we was leaving,
you know, you know out brother.
We pretty physical, you know,
so I was like alright man, cool!
You know, hit him in the
chest like that, you know.
[ Laughter ]
And, and I'm walking
off, and I go, like,
did you just hit the president?
[ Laughter ]
But you know, but then immediately
it was like, you know, yeah, but,
he was cool with that, you know,
because he understood, you know,
that you mean something to him.
I mean he means something
to you, right!
[ Laughter ]
I got, don't care to twist it.
Yeah, but so, he, you know,
he understood that,
that, that you know.
He understands his
place in our history.
There was no doubt in
that moment for me.
And, but, but what an honor.
Wow! Another one would
be Chuck Brown, you know.
Yeah. Chuck's, Chuck, I
still, I love that man.
I just, you know, I share a wall
with him and President Obama
and Bill Cosby down at
Ben's Chili Bowl, and,
which is pretty cool to me.
But Chuck was just
such a cool brother.
Listened to my show every
morning, four hours every morning,
every morning, was
just the coolest guy.
I still have not been able to
bring myself to watch his Unsung.
It's taped, but I haven't, they
asked me to be a part of it
and I just wouldn't do it.
I just, I don't know.
It was kind of emotional for me.
And so, but, but I will watch it.
But Chuck was just such a,
just such a cool brother,
and so about D.C. You know, and
I, and I guess that takes me
to the third person which
is Mayor Marion Barry,
who was totally about D.C.
[ Applause ]
You know, yeah.
And, and people around the country
sometimes don't understand it.
They go you know how you
support that guy, you know.
It's like, shoot, man, please.
It's a D.C. thing.
You just, you know, he was about the
people of D.C. long before he took
over the mayor's position.
You know, he was always about D.C.,
and I admired him greatly for that.
You know, I remember, you know, I
mean we all know what happened with,
with the crack smoking thing, and I
remember calling my dad in Detroit
that night because I was so upset.
You know, I just, I just get tired
of seeing us get torn
down, you know.
And so that night I called
my dad and I was crying.
I was just, you know,
telling him what happened.
They had this thing
on video tape, dad.
Well, blah, blah, blah,
went on and on.
Finally my dad said, Mmmm.
[ Laughter ]
And that was it.
So I'm, I'm in the process of
writing a book now, and that's part
of what I want to write about, and
it's just called Mmm, that part,
because, because when you live that
long and seen that much, you know,
you come, it's like [inaudible].
Mmm.
[ Laughter ]
I seen some stuff in my days.
You know, so we should
all live to Mmm.
You know, I wish you all Mmm.
[ Laughter ]
But you know, I admire
those guys so,
and so many times I've
heard people say to me, wow!
Actually somebody asked me in an
interview just recently, is it,
you know, it's like three
people that represent D.C. You,
Chuck Brown, and Mayor Barry.
And it, it's so what is that,
what does that mean to you?
I said that means I'm next.
[ Laughter ]
What's it mean to you?
I'm next. I mean I hope it's a
long time, but that's a fact.
That's a fact.
I'm next.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, man. But you know, it's, now
see I just rambled, but you know, I,
I have to say this, that
death I do not fear.
It's always been fascinating
to me that the thing
that we are all guaranteed
we fear the most.
And, but, you know, I used
to be, but I remember.
I was very young, I think at 22, 23,
when President Anwar Sadat
was assassinated in Egypt.
And I remember seeing
an interview with him,
and it was two days
before he was assassinated,
and you know, he knew it.
You know, I mean pretty much like
Dr. King the night, you know.
The mountain top speaks, you know,
where he just, you
saw it in his eyes.
I was like, you know,
you, you just knew.
And so they asked him about
it because these reports were,
you know, it seemed eminent, and
he said, they asked was he afraid.
He said absolutely not.
There's no man who can
take me before my time.
That was so deep to me.
I'm like you could, you
could pull the trigger,
but God sent you, he's
bringing me home.
That's, you know, and I don't
mean to start preaching,
but that's how I feel about that.
You can pull the trigger, but, so
with that I say, you know, I, I,
I love, I love this journey
so much that I'm on here.
I love life, and with that
said, I stand here ready
to go right this minute
because I don't fear that.
You know, I don't fear that.
I look forward to sitting with Dr.
King one day and seeing my dad again
and all that stuff, you know, so.
Wow! I just went a long ways from --
[ Laughter ]
-- from starting out at 15.
I, I don't even know how I got here.
[ Laughter ]
But, but I've had a blessed career.
You know, to start in
radio at the age of 15,
especially in a major market.
Detroit was the fifth largest
market in the country at the time,
and that's where I got my start.
I mean it was, now it's 48.
People left there like
crazy, you know.
The, the automobile
industry has just suffered
so much through the years.
But, you know, I always
felt so blessed that,
you know, I got to start so young.
Most of the guys that I was
competing with for jobs in radio,
you know, most of them had
done their stint in the Nam.
You know, they're 22, 23 years old.
You know, shoot, at 22, 23 I had
eight years' experience, you know,
in a major market in Detroit.
I mean, I was a tough
candidate, you know,
when they called me to come here.
Wow! It was to Disco 93,
and I thought no way.
I'm not doing that.
A disco station?
Because to me disco meant just
stringing songs together, you know.
No involvement from
the DJ, whatever.
But my oldest brother had always
taught me to always listen.
You know, you have
to listen at least,
so I decided to come
here and talk with them.
You'll love this.
They fly me in.
They pick me up at the
airport and take me
for the interview at
Arlington Cemetery.
[ Laughter ]
Right.
I'm like, man, this
is Washington, boy!
This is, this is so
clandestine you know.
What?
[ Laughter ]
Why here? And it was so weird.
But they took, you know, I listened
to the radio station and found
out it was a little more than
disco and decided to come.
The station I was at, I felt like
I had accomplished everything
that I could there, that
there was, you know, there,
it was the biggest station in that
chain, and this is owned by NBC,
so I felt that there were a
lot more opportunities there.
I was making $13,000
a year in Detroit.
I came here making $28,500.
I thought I was rich.
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
Making twice the money, but
they didn't tell me the cost
of living was three times as much.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, oh man, surprise!
I was broke.
Oh my goodness.
I struggled, man.
I'm telling you.
I struggled so hard that first
couple years because, you know,
I also lost my side hustle.
People didn't know who I was, so,
you know, you're not MC-ing shows
and you know, no, no, ain't
no side money coming in.
So it was tight, man.
I remember I had taken
these pictures.
I had these pictures developed.
Everybody here remembers
pictures developed.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, you talk to some they wouldn't
have any idea what you're talking
about now.
[ Laughter ]
But they were the last pictures of
my grandfather and I couldn't afford
to get them out of the shop.
It was $28.
And I'll never forget that.
And this went on for
about three months.
They kept calling me, and finally
I got enough money together to go
up there and get the pictures,
and they had destroyed them.
You know, it was gone.
It was gone.
But, but you know, it's
stuff like that helps
to keep you grounded, you know.
It's, you know, it's like, well an
old saying I heard that the best way
to teach your kids about
money is to not have any.
[ Laughter ]
They learn the value
of it real fast then.
And so, you know, I think
we've all had those experiences
and those struggles, and you
know, it's, God turned things
around very quickly
for me after that.
And I've been very blessed through
the years to live a life that is,
that is just unimaginable to me.
You know, it's just, you know,
I mean so many years I started
living beyond what my dreams were
that, I don't know, it's just,
you know, it's just God's will.
And I thank Him for the
light that He's given me.
And, and, and I should say not
just, you know, financially.
That's secondary to the wife He's
given me, to the kids He's given me,
to the grandkids that
He's blessed me with.
You know, I, He's just put such
wonderful people in my life that,
you know, I was thinking
about this because last night.
Well yesterday Bob Johnson invited
me to a fundraiser that he had
for Hillary Clinton, so I go
there and here I'm sitting
at a table next to Hillary Clinton.
You know, it's just like, wow!
This is cool.
I never met her.
I met her husband a few times.
But, so then we went
out to celebrate Bob's
70th birthday last night,
and so I was thinking
about this this morning.
You know, Bob's historic figure.
He's our first black billionaire,
and, and, but then I was thinking
about those things I
just listed to you.
My wife and my kids, and I
said you know what, I don't,
I can't say I'm richer than him,
but I can tell you this,
I'm just as rich as him.
You know, that this is worth, you
can't put a value on what I have.
You know, a billion dollars.
Give me a choice of
those two things,
I'm going to take this every time,
you know, because in the end,
we leave here with the
exact same amount of money.
[ Laughter ]
That don't mean nothing.
It really doesn't.
So you know, I'm just so blessed
to have the love of my family,
the love of my people, you know.
I just, you know, you all
fill me up today, you know,
just having me here
to be a part of this.
Again, the reception
I got coming in,
it's just, it's, it's overwhelming.
And I appreciate --
>> Man #1: We love you, Donnie!
[ Laughter ]
Thank you!
>> Man #2: That was too perfect.
>> Donnie Simpson: That was!
That was perfect, man!
[ Laughter ]
They're going to think
I set you up, brother.
[ Laughter ]
We're already up here dapping
each other up and stuff.
[ Laughter ]
So yeah, he came with Donnie, man.
That was a set-up.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, but I, I was told to leave
some time for questions and answers,
so I'll do that, but, but
thank you for having me.
I really, really appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
Thank you!
[ Laughter ]
So anybody got a question.
Ok, go ahead, brother.
>> Man #3: This is more
than, than a question.
This is to say thank
you to this man.
A lot of you know me as
ebaby [phonetic], a poet.
May 8 of 2004 there was a
young lady, seven years old,
Chelsea Cromartie was
killed by a stray bullet.
Donnie was at the funeral.
The mayor was at the funeral.
A lot of people at the
funeral, and the father asked me
to perform a poem called
Da-ah's Angel.
Donnie got in touch with people
through the radio for me to come
up to the station so he could
play it that next morning
so all of his fans can hear me.
That boosted my career a lot.
>> Donnie Simpson: Wow.
>> Man #3: And I'm only here,
and I made sure I was the
first one here and I sat there.
This is not a set-up.
I know [inaudible] wasn't.
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, here to thank him,
and as he named Chuck Brown
and, and Marion Barry.
I thank you, I thank you, and
I say this, listening to you
so long I want to say bro,
I want to say thank you bro,
and I hope you accept that.
>> Donnie Simpson:
Man, I do, brother.
Thank you, brother!
[ Applause ]
>> Man #3: I appreciate that.
>> Donnie Simpson: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Wow! Thank you!
Yes.
>> Man #4: Yes, many years
ago you did Video Soul --
>> Donnie Simpson: Yeah.
>> Man #4: And I forgot the name of
that group, but there was this guy,
he always called you his brother.
>> Donnie Simpson:
J.T. Cool and the Gang.
>> Man #4: [inaudible]
[ Laughter ]
>> Donnie Simpson: Yeah,
J.T., the lead singer.
>> Man #4: I just forgot the name
of who, you know, what's his name
and everything, but I just remember
you all looked so much alike.
>> Donnie Simpson: We do, man.
I tell, we had picture, a
picture taken that was so,
so classic where even our mothers
looked at them and just go --
[ Laughter ]
Wow! My twin brother, and
I have a real twin brother.
We don't look anywhere
near close like me and J.T.
[ Laughter ]
It's not 3:00.
I'm not working yet.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's my man, though.
Cool brother, J.T. Yes, ma'am?
>> Woman #1: Two, well, one
question and one comment.
The question is how have you
seen the music industry change.
>> Donnie Simpson: Sorry.
>> Woman #1: Over the years,
the opportunities to be paid
and also how radio has gone from
the regular radio to, you know, the,
the one that we have in the stereo
with all of that to the computer
and streaming and all of that.
>> Donnie Simpson: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Woman #1: So I'd like to
hear your resposne to that.
And also my favorite memory
of you is Teena Marie
singing to you by the piano.
>> Donnie Simpson: Wow!
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Woman #1: That was very nice.
Thank you [inaudible].
>> Donnie Simpson: Wow!
Wow! You know, I'd actually
forgotten about that,
and then the morning after
Teena died, somebody posted on,
on Facebook and I saw
it and went wow.
I just, I forget about,
you know, I, I don't know.
I never think the go-to
video that, well,
you got video with
all of these people.
But yeah, that was really special.
She was, Teena was really, really
cool, something, something special.
But you know, for me, well,
you asked about the
music industry and radio.
You know, it's, it's funny,
Jimmy Jam and Terry Lewis
and I have had this conversation
about how our industries
parallel each other.
And, and I was struggling
with what they have become.
You know, that so much of the
creativity has been taken out of it,
out of, you know, you know, music.
Especially when you
talk about R&B music.
You know, it's pretty
sad state to me.
And it, and it bothers me that,
you know, we just, you know,
used to be the top 30
songs in the country
on the Billboard hot
charts you'd see the O'Jay's
and Teddy Pendergrass, and
of course, Michael Jackson.
But you know, you had real soul
music that charted all the time,
and it just doesn't happen anymore.
You know, I mean if, if you want
to call Rihanna soul, you know,
it's just, you know, not for me.
It's not R&B.
And so, you know, so, so I hate
that, but you know, with radio,
it's been stripped
of its personality.
You know, broadcast radio.
And what happened was that they,
there was a new rating
service called PPM.
Well, it was a new ratings system.
For years it was done by diary
where they would send you a diary.
You would keep it for two weeks.
You were supposed to write down
what radio station you listened to
and how long you listened.
That didn't happen.
What happened is you go, God,
I forgot to send this thing in.
Let, alright, well last Thursday
I listened to WKYS for 14 hours.
So it was imperfect.
So I get, so they tried to come
up with something that
could correct that.
They came up with these
little boxes that you wear.
It looked like a pager.
And it picks up whatever
it's hearing.
Now, problem with it is that it
may not be your choice of radio.
If we're sitting in the
Cheesecake Factory chilling,
whatever they playing,
this is getting all the credit even
though I don't want to hear this.
You know. We go to Old
Navy shopping, same thing.
You know. So that's imperfect also.
But what happened was
that, for black stations
in particular across this country.
I mean the impact was immediate.
Stations that were perennial
number ones for 25, 30 years,
went from number one
to 15, 16th place.
Immediately.
It was unbelievable.
Never seen anything like it.
And then radio stations
that, we had the first book,
we had a radio station
here came up number one.
What was it?
Oh, WFRE. We're radio people sitting
in this going who the hell are they?
[ Laughter ]
Number, never heard of them.
And so a country and western
station from Frederick, Maryland,
was number one in D.C.
I'm like, come on, man.
You got --
[ Laughter ]
Come on, man.
I'm telling you.
It was, it was that deep.
I remember having this conversation
with Stevie Wonder one night.
And I'm not dropping names, but --
[ Laughter ]
-- but really.
We, we were talking.
We were hanging out.
We were talking about it, and I
asked him how was his station.
He owns a station, has since the mid
70's in California, in Los Angeles.
And I said how is, I can't
even think of the call letters.
Kindness, love, joy, KJLH.
Kindness, joy, love, and happiness.
I said I, how, how are
you doing with KJLH?
He says man, we're getting killed.
He said this, man this
PPM thing is crazy,
and anybody believes this is crazy.
This is ridiculous.
I said I know, man.
I said, you know, this
is like trying,
take radio from black people.
You know, and, and there
were inquiries into that
because it seemed so calculated.
But, so anyway, in response to that,
radio stations got to the point
where they started trying
to just program music
because they wanted
to get those hits.
When you're in Old Navy
and the Cheesecake Factory
and they figure they got
a better chance of doing
that with music playing than
with someone talking, ok.
That's one of the problems.
The other problem, and this is
probably bigger than that, actually,
is that all of the advertising
dollars went to the internet.
Ok? So, you know, that impacted
us in terms of salaries and stuff.
Jim Vance, to drop another name --
[ Laughter ]
These's my boys.
So yeah, me and Vance were
talking about it one night and just
about how, like, you know, in radio
and television because of this,
because those advertising
dollars had gone to the internet
that salaries were coming down.
And the kind of numbers that
I posted as a personality
for local radio, you'll
never see again.
It'll never happen.
Because the money is not there.
It's just not there.
It's gone to the internet.
They found an alternative
way to advertise.
And Jim Vance and I were
talking about the fact
that we were lucky that, in our
business, we were in radio and TV,
we were just experiencing pay cuts.
Print was closing their doors
because of this same issue.
So, so when you have
less revenue to pay,
you want to cut down a personality.
If, if you can, if you can
prove that it's just music,
if I just play these three
songs in this order every day,
then you don't need
to pay Donnie Simpson.
Yeah. But, what they're finding
out is that well, maybe we do.
[ Laughter ]
You know, because the, the only
thing, you know, from, this is,
this is not rocket science.
From day one I learned that the
only thing that makes you listen
to me other than the
guy next to me is me,
is the way, the way it's presented.
We all get the same records.
You know, you can hear
the same music anywhere.
You know, and, and, and to me,
when, for radio to try to make it
so music intensive, to take, to take
the personality out of it at a time
when you can least afford
to be music intensive.
Man, I got all the music
I can stand right here.
In my iPhone, my iPad,
Pandora, Spotify.
Good luck out playing music to me.
You know, I need somebody
to present it to me,
to do something different with it.
So that's the state of radio.
That's, sorry.
Yes?
>> Woman #2: I wondered
since you started off
in Detroit [inaudible]
Detroit is in such bad shape --
>> Donnie Simpson: Yeah.
>> Woman #2: -- have you
done any humanitarian things
to help [inaudible]
back on its feet?
>> Donnie Simpson: I
just try to stay away.
[ Laughter ]
No.
No, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
No, no. Well, you know
what, I mean I, I,
I am home a couple times a year.
Part of a, this is not Detroit,
but it's kind of Detroit,
but have involved in a project to,
to bring some clean water to Flint.
I mean that's, you know,
even the people of Detroit,
as bad as things are
in Detroit right now,
that's been Detroit's
focus is Flint.
You know, trying to
save, help save Flint.
But you know, I mean I've
been asked to come back home,
make appearances in
Detroit, which I do.
You know, I've always
supported Detroit.
You know, I'm, people here always
say how long you been here.
I go, you know, 40 years now.
Well you a D.C. boy.
I say I could be here 140
years, I'm from Detroit.
[ Laughter ]
You know, that, that's, and
when I'm done, send me back.
Right. But you know, so yeah, I mean
I've always been a part of Detroit
and a part of things
to try to help it.
It's a bad situation there.
I mean make no mistake
about it, but you know.
The former mayor was a very
good friend of mine, Dave Bing.
Dave, well a lot of people
know him from basketball.
He played in NBA.
He's from D.C. D.C. boy.
So Dave would have me back
to be a part of things to try
to help Detroit, you know,
as, as much as we can.
Yeah, but it's bad.
I mean it's, you know, the
population has gone from 2.6 million
to 800,000 in 30 years
in Detroit, you know.
There are blocks, you go there where
it's, you know, where there used
to be 40 homes, now there's two.
You know, I mean it's just,
it's like a bomb dropped there.
It, it's really, really sad.
But, but you know what,
I'll say this, too, though,
that those two homes that
you do see, look at the lawn.
[ Laughter ]
Proud. Proud.
You know, it's a proud
city, and, and yeah.
So you know, it, it's tough but
people haven't given up hope.
You know, so, oh, is that it.
[ Laughter ]
Well, hey, thank you all again.
God bless you!
Thank you!